allez on poursuit ce JT avec une idée de
sortie pour ce week-end direction
Joué-lès-Tours et le parc de la Rabière
à l'occasion de la 26ème édition des
années jouées au programme une
cinquantaine de spectacles gratuits et
ça commence dès ce vendredi soir et sur
place pour nous faire vivre le début des
festivités on retrouve Sarah gros
oui bonsoir Hélène ici il fait beau il
fait bon on sent que l'ambiance monte
progressivement je suis au parc de la
Rabière et c'est ici à 19h30 que se
tiendra le coup d'envoi pour cette 26e
édition des années jouées et c'est la
fanfare théâtrale des groom ce qui
ouvrira le bas le quelques minutes après
avec son spectacle la baronnade et
durant ce festival vous verrez aussi
plus tard déambuler toutes sortes de
choses étranges des hommes avec des
bocaux sur la tête ou encore un héros de
la mythologie grecque alors à mes côtés
Olivier catin bonsoir Olivier vous êtes
le vous êtes le directeur artistique de
ce festival alors l'année dernière on
dansait cette année ont misé sur le
bizarre pourquoi avoir choisi ce thème
en fait on vient de traverser tous
autant qu'on est une période bizarre
avec on est sorti du covid il y a eu des
événements climatiques cette année on
renoue avec le soleil et puis j'avais
envie de cette thématique ça m'a permis
d'aller chercher 24 compagnies qui
proposent des choses qui vont de
l'infémininement petit
l'infiniment grand donc il va y en avoir
pour tout le monde derrière vous voyez
un bateau qui s'est échoué ça va être un
spectacle pour pour les jeunes publics
avec la compagnie Eka
on a la compagnie civicivia qui nous
vient d'Espagne qui va nous montrer des
machines infernales on va avoir
Achille à qui laisse en espagnol qui va
déambuler ce soir avec la compagnie
progéniture qui va mais voilà les arts
de la rue c'est ça et alors cette
thématique bizarre vous avez des
bizarres c'est ça m'a permis aussi de
traiter de sujets un peu plus durs un
peu plus voilà avec la compagnie cumulus
par exemple qui vont traîner des objets
un peu insolites qui vont faire du bruit
puis ils vont se retrouver à un endroit
et là on va les voir
théâtraliser leurs mots alors mot maux
mais aussi leurs mots dans une symphonie
des mots voilà merci Olivier un
programme bien complet et bien chargé à
l'heure et voilà Hélène de quoi bien
conclure sur cette thématique
car du bizarre vous n'en manquerez pas
difficile déjà de ne pas apercevoir
l'omnis géant de 38 tonnes composés de
containers et qui mesure près de 20
mètres de hauteur vous pourrez l'admirer
en lumière et en couleur samedi à 22h30
place Nelson Mandela
merci merci Sarah et merci à Aurélie
Renaud qui vous accompagne pour les
moyens techniques